welcome to hari sadhus the channel where
we discussed the latest tech news and
delve into the newest tech products
today we're taking a look at whether you
should buy the a 700 K or the 8086 k but
before we delve into that make sure to
hit that subscribe button if you guys
would like to see more videos just like
this one first of all before we go any
further I want to tell you guys that
they're not going to be any benchmarks
in this video if there are already very
many benchmarks on the internet and I
simply want to offer another perspective
for you guys so as you guys all know the
i7 8700 K was a rush to release from
intohe at the beginning of october last
year and it had six cores and twelve
threads with the base frequency of 3.7
gigahertz and a max turbo frequency of
4.7 rehearse we were all hoping to hear
about the expected octa-core processor
and the Z 390 platform from Intel at
Computex however we did not hear
anything about that instead we heard
about an overhyped 28 core CPU from
Intel which was completely destroyed by
a nice new thread Ripper CPUs if you
guys are interested in the Intel 28 core
CPU or the AMD 304 series er coming out
in August then make sure to click the
link right here but anyways at Computex
intel also revealed a new CPU called the
8086 k which is going to be yet another
hexa-core processor however the base and
boost clock of the 8086 k is just a mere
300 megahertz faster than 280 700 K with
its base frequency at 4 gigahertz and
has maxed turbo frequency at five-year
Hertz so it's pretty much just been 8700
case which Intel is selling for a much
more expensive price it was actually
expected to cost as much as five hundred
and thirty dollars on release however
the price is actually much cheaper at
$425 at that price point that 8086 K is
only $45 more than the 80s 700 K so is
it worth it now well first let's take a
look at the performance of these two
chips well they are just pretty much
identical chips with just a few hundred
megahertz difference in speed but how
does it differ when it's overclocked so
ask for the 8700 K pretty much all 80
similar case and overclock easily to 5
years provided efficient cooling and
maybe even more if you're lucky 8086 k
can pretty much overclock to five point
two gigahertz and if you're lucky you
may be able to squeeze out a little bit
more than that so when it's overclocked
it's actually just a 200 micro
difference so unfortunately not that
much really recently there has been a
lot of hype around the 8086 k because
this one person was able to overclock
the 8086 k using liquid nitrogen all the
way to seven point two four gigahertz
and so that clearly shows how much
potential the 8086 hay has right oh not
really because if you go back a couple
of months
the 8700 k was actually able to
overclock all the way to seven point
three gigahertz
granted it did take them a couple of
CPUs to get to that number but that just
shows how close to eighty seven okay and
the 8086 k really are unfortunately
there really is not that big of a
difference at least on the performance
side so what about price how is the
price going to differ between the two
CPUs overall honestly I believe that the
8086 K will drop to $400 in just a
couple of weeks on most retailers online
like Amazon and Newegg right now you can
get the 8700 K on you egg and Amazon for
about 350 dollars and sometimes even
less so about a $50 difference is where
we're going to be expecting between
these two chips so you're pretty much
paying an extra $50 for just two hundred
megahertz of performance so it's really
not worth it finally before I discuss
whether or not you should buy this chip
and if it really is worth it I think
that it is important to point out that
this chip is an anniversary trip so it
has that name associated with it while
the 87 RK does not so as a result even a
couple years from now you will always
have a special ship if you opt to go
with the 8086 K so if you are interested
in that then this may be something to
consider
so is the 8086 k worth it well for 99%
of you guys in my opinion it is
definitely not worth it because the
performance that it provides is so
marginal but the price is $50 more and I
really don't think the price is worth
the performance in all honesty no one
should actually buy this chip music
really provides nothing over the a
dissembler enrique however humans don't
always make purchases just based on
whether or not it's worth it sometimes
people just wanted and that's completely
fine as long as that doesn't lead to
detriment in other PC parts as a result
I believe that this chip is designed for
the novelty builder who already has all
the top of line products on the
mainstream platform and they don't
really care about extra fifty dollars
and would like to have a novelty
associated with this chip so considering
that if you're in that situation and you
do want this chip for the novelty and a
little bit extra speed that you get on
top of the 87 arcade
then I definitely do think that it is
worth it for you guys but if you're
looking for a value then this is not the
chip for you however if you guys are an
average PC builder or gamer then I
definitely recommend that you guys stay
away from this chip and if you want the
best performance for the price ratio and
down they recommend you guys go with the
8700 cake or even better than 2700 X
which is the best value for the price
and if you really want performance that
I recommend you guys wait for the 9700 K
so really this chip is only for the
novelty builder who would like to have
some uniqueness associated with their
build but that's just what I think how
do you guys feel about this chip do you
guys think to the 8086 k is completely
pointless and at this point intuitive
action leads to eight core 16 thread CPU
ask the 8086 k or do you think that this
chip has its own special place make sure
to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
I'm curious as to what you guys think so
make sure to post your thoughts also if
you guys like see more videos just like
this then make sure to hit that
subscribe button and drop a like if you
guys like this video but until next time
bye
[Music]